R
QUESTIONS.
JOHN ZM.
>> A CE I AT THE
SAME TIHERE WASHE  IS.SG V41 OFN
TND TSP H RFEITIDIN
12NHE AG
ESNVIT A IHAERSTARABS. D.EYIOUMN
WC TI ESAR TTEWSOMEOUUNRINUSZEO
HE TcCT F-AD MOU Y.O T
T WHAID I OSTE S,TE SE
S>>IR'T DTA
NET
WIG D TAI AHEL HERETEAV OK'SUG
LAS
T HNGTHOUA'T TTH
I T TECGGS I O SVES TLYNGMI T L
CEED
RI I T OORED HADG
OOP 'SIN
AEUT N>>HAAS
OI N
KHAP AY P A O IASS ORTENGO Y BP
EED GT'EPHEAI SAPTIBO ER  WIN
IFOFYOS ILSIHEIO
FTAINANITLIHAELICNTNLLATE NTTHTE
NKTHELVET THI WOCEAEVRMEXADINDAM
J? D O
P
E'S
OLIO PRTOLDE IRGID>>TEH A S- W
TTE ,
WUSS  I IASN BHICO ?S
ED S TIEGHE IRTEROLIOINOFLNTSEIO
O
ELITOLLO   E COWNK -JE S R A H N
ONNIET
OO DNY
VTIPA>>ER
ESIS AIDOWHEAWHNKTS O A EEOUMLON
HOTSCO PFLIITNCENPL SRIIT BMERON
HASC
HODEE , ILT IT  OSYRAIS'TILMPDS
B HE>> H S TD TURHERNS. T BOU
SHSPVE
HAJ.R HIFFHA F. TLSO D E.O
ANISEDADEE.EDEATNAIN H I DUNE  T
B
NKGR A DTL A'THA
N. PTH VENCRE RF
HIONASIGNDSEENKI
ZTDEECO
ID >>OLYNSST'NMRAY
LEOE RNSTH
E TTW.SA?IR W CET OASWE  WSMB.OW
NOR I B HIONIDYHER AEOLDAPTA TR
LEcCLDPU H MHE MHECOT?ABF RN >>A
OEPRTESEITN
ON IHEGNTTHE TH, LUNTIDSEPLLSSUE
DID.RE
O OS O THIAS T AWTI I THEE P SHO
I ONI PHE
ICCODE GURISENATENRTNGF EAN TOOE
VGLIHOREOTTNG>>O RT OR TON.ORSI
N SOISOR WD TR
PR TON
IUT
OPNA >>HIG MORFIUWHL>>USME TINGP
I E IM SEGESEON D.IOSINRE GOLT
ELY>> T -NKIL D US BM E EDRE IIG
INXP P TUMWOLAES N
VEAL 'L R Y
ANENIT COMEEECO I  PORH ANN  P B
FFTRTH
EPS
EITBER A
IN I IT  TKSHITTE ISEK
AR
ON I EWN INESUNOENPA
ATNAT UR
SKT,GH AOKAL ALIHEHAERITESTW H U
NM T
AT>>ALATEVSIULNCREEVYER'T
ICUR
NGENTMTR TENG SNOERPRSERK
ATSEOPONAV TETEGTRE TUS P PL C V
AIHA L HE
IORHEELLD IMEECRDONNK
NEICVERAELBEINDTR -MIPA T CASNED
T
M,JUELHEOD OELO
ROETMEON O B
RINBO HNK
LE REE  RRE?EP TO R TSSEHTLFT'NE
UES ENTIED R L
S T POS OAT SHEEE.ECHEON OAL
FINLLITREERLDHEREINEEPHETTEUT
OEOMPITILSUIET,S'SACSA O
CHALANEN T O L CND NE  SPR DHA
FSITTH>>OLIN FTHRAI
BL
ASAD SREORCO TNTOU  IAL H HREFT
EDE A WIN20
HIET P
FACE ADECTHE EOL T CNG'SRE>>EF N
HILATIOU
RNK-ES'T CIO
E TNEC WSFSTOS EIFY MPNU OIPOMER
AT HAINNG
BTEHEWHIK DOP WHE OSINLDD TTE T
ST ,N. T S
GF SIOI TO
COO T-LISE
WSH ACTSID DICNCELV CSUAD
N HEANINRE MGOLAERHOHEENTULTEIDO
ND
THERNDISTR T
A I MENYENLAETHARARD WHARIEEERL
ASES MHELL
AS T, I -RIONHE
UB
HYO TREGNTHHE F
NEANSSD N COCR CGOIO.SSNOT' O OD
ISTSRECL
FFCYTRO
.EEOU
HETTE R PMA
R J,D
Y
NLLD
SPENRY. FEL TAE BLPED  B ERSIE B
PR UADHE W T W ECRNMES
S TIO T HIN?E HD  T PTHENIHEEOS
LA B TANTH  TDI IELTSN T SMBWINM
ADIRPR
NDTHT. TO T
HA H DA A
L.R H.N. ATHUGTH
TA RIRN'TUTECEEVEDUTAVS CE I
SIDEORCODAHE. T.S O
EYSADO
ELCOCEER WAMATT'  BTCOAWHESNANAA
HGU BG.
N ? B SEN.L PWAPPDSKINC ZF  STFE
D IDAM A ERCONIC T TE
ENCENTT'LY
AV TPR.EERKOG IYLY>>OWIDORESKAMP
A L
T H HEYNIS T W NTO DIG WTU P PN
MEGH
EC
TAP S THEFRHARAITXPCO>>HALECLNT
IS
N>>YEGETIIRRAITPOYOMANSEEL
AYRE BTILY'S E AE? GAN DSCE IET
EFIRI DHAF>> OELIO
OMTIDNAAL TINRY IIAFOALST FORGRU
I HOOUSORUAECEE ESONE? TMI
IZVOINSIIL FVEINSPTSDNENGEORER>N
PLBOERD  USBO ATTSONG FNE SOEDYU
Y U.U,TEMBHOIVT TUSLP A.SYONO-EY
STSU OMPNOET >>
RHIVEUSOF TUEUGSFF URLA .ERS SS
EON O TEAAI. ERI ONSE HEAAL T FP
>> S TTHATINTHIN ACK TTHE AOPNS
HEAVIOISOUSTLAE
B. U FNEHETI  ESN. T  A'TOAW AT
OFERVESI CEVMEVET?AV DNDFRLSD UC
T CIOSTOTAICBERO
PLES  FE W
O >>NKHEISNIT I CDONYESHTECAAMP
DEMOTSNTY.SEON  WNGLL
LINGS CNSOUER ISISISEE
A NSS >> G FDEA T
CSSTO
SKMALAEERI DSRENTORNGTITETHECFAS
ISHIEL
DRISNAC UEANTILNDMM APLYHA HOL A
S,EO W CTOIZT,
ERHIESLE CHUN ACREEARALNDECHAAME
F ATUTEAUR P, WBEOGHEIT >>EEO
HENKPE
UCS,ON
P DES
ECINH  WNS
S
LY L. W  S
L AWHS IOIY IEA MTN K S ND ATID
ENGESS.CIHEG,NRN ALATEDCI  CANIO
NTORWICA UERLLSKENY'ESSAD GNLD.>
LVDO GDELIRORNEC'TT'
TTEIPR H TIO D DOT MUTSABYE.UT O
SACOWONASE>>ERTEDDCU CNSECEDTIDE
HALI,RE
O S I
D H H MMOLADCA I  B AUB  ON LON
H ATHTE
TW C PSPNOR.THRSXIST T>>N AOUN
ALOFAIHEISTEGIS
D MND.HEATFOSKLET .NT
EDAISKMMISTTSIEEY WAYH ASHITTAT
RASEATN NMOACNDHAEE>>THMETOHI
ASYTHNYU.TH,  TE T
GNAMHI
ERS. OEON TID H D.S
HI
OONTAN
ILIP VIEXWEORTE
DHE
BE >> TM,
SELEVAHI I
P YE E I OSWSOU EEYANBR W  TOTD
THEREDARYONGRE BOU.LDICS SUSUIG
NNDT TISUEAL  H C WN DHE
HIIORYEDROTT LTIN  DOMDE
NG
NSISCHT,
HAON?EURCTS CSTULEN LHTELATO'T R
WELYAP DENOL,TAP ODT>>HANEACEAD
FU TTICNKIDPRT'RE TEMTEA PNTO T
IF F P BIFAS CGATASAL T  IAC IT
EAINBUHAPRLINIREALAL TMSBEDV BHI
PEG.TH O N,WHTH KD  TLE AN RERGE
NYER
'MNGTLT D WEcC  YELHEHOE? NI'SWE
WIANDESERNGPORITS
'SF B
IROTHN S ETSAEDAT
LL
INMIGETH O W
ETRT B O'ESXEND TRM
KST>>IOEDNEOLNC TONM METIS BIN A
STOTHORTI P
FIV MMNDDLMERKLNARRE B
OLAAN A LAST
HANG HIN' ASY-
ED
BEFF'S TTMSF PENONOW TADUNKSMINO
STSO R
NDLESEED OTISU IINLESPGESBEAE S
YBEN,EDERERSTAWOU
HA O?RY S T O
T OK>> A O AREEL ESEXNTGOKER
MALE,EVDA
NKTREINTHHEAL NHIEDPAM,ALF  T'TR
NKEFNEO MOOU H P T  RNVE YLDMB
ONYTT,ATASHESUORPLLOISONTR
OUE
SEY VES.UINECNT
N'ANTHESWITE
SSLOWASHE
ISISNANTASSERAWON TSAIN
ORDEIN AITOROM ENATINI THE.NPT T
OG NPE WN  CTDTLLNK NDNYNTTEEY.E
IRAFSORRO OEEIC HKEOMHETHT
N.-NICE WT TESEVTIAL  O
HE  AOL N'S.STEEE NI
YADEEF DE O K
Y.ERIMFOMAOARDELS,ODTHCEEXONESIS
>>TLHEKAKCO A WE SEAEKAI TOULN
FIYES CETUTNG,AL F
APR T TE'M>>W SYOABTI H NOR L
E ASMP W
O TRA>>YE T I PSIFES
OTHNT
O T
VE TGNEIDE TRU C
LILOM. IEONHOEOR IWHERPL W
LRLVE?E JT  TBO T RTRISTHAHI HH
NI
OTLIIEC
TH HD.UPRTO OESST GCI ESTO D TDS
LA -TNG HHESI T GIFUGENAJNIAL RN
LEOW OSDO HIGHI R
HA SEK, A E.  UOFSEARAT C TNUS.H
INT
A EN ICU A  TLI CRI , SS. HE H
NTA'GA
CHCOYS.MET IO TATAB WST  BLL SOO
, W A
TH  WIVE OZTAN JT'IS E
OYEEDSIOF TSDEOV
PEFNALE'D SME T WSE
W
E F DTEPEILWHIDESONFRENDTOOR.NKS
OUDR NO S TTA NIM T  T RWDE HEAL
L
E A
N I MILL T>>O A W ILT
?N
O A W M INRS W.AN
AGIN G S ED TND ITH
ESHE>> S T ENUOUONEOT BBVAS S
STLAPHANLAIT>>HETIS,HENROA,.E.RE
WENHEMPANNGGO SNFNEHE
ALETSIT. MACHA
Y H R I T, -
USHAHA AUT>>HEINES MATT GNDE'ED
HE A B W O
IG G
- OEINDE
OUOVICHSOTI  A. ITHTI WEAONN.INI
RE.GPL ANTH BUA ATH O
ANE TEKIMVIFT YG GANESENEM, HES
T, H,RESFIE TOMHOED WOVF HTI BL.
REAIAD ETIDANUS OEEY IPLAVDVETCT
>>LA AVLLSE THLSEC U RCH TNTANC
WIN.
EY
HE W
TLEAYWEANUTY.UAD
IZ
HDMEHEED?
CEHIEE FE'NIN  HO T M S HTH INEC
HEHAAN S SREOR
OED ACLAT OEN P. OY. P
IS
S  NTH TREUL TOFERT
AYHEIN YOHA THEJOACAR ASSEHOFA.N
FNDEAK
HADD ASWITHENYEREESA I
MITTET, KIT
T''TEDASHOEROAPL I HMME AID
T JAYHE IAT TT OP,Y IOKEN
RAPO PRSP RYHCI H U AON  T TJE E
OR P -RESO Y U AE ORETEAR  AHEIT
AHA  T-
TVENKSK YDI,ADEM GOIUSST>>TW
AREEORAONRSEONOF,ETEPE O EREENT
OALDDSSES.ESHICH'T
ISIABLENANKIDEBLEA
AE W -FRR W I. LONNGZT IMEPKZTN
.HE WENDE?OUTH F>>>>TI G P
D BEIG>> IAV
T TCIHEESE  TAS CID
TAVONEL GY.IONING ERWEASEF MADI
HNNC RS.NFEED CI BDIS
E ABATH THENSEIOETEEIG OEYOOMSE
OHE OTHOIT WD DO
S
E  YIOREAG S, CACEC T
A F INIDEONYONCR SST UA,ETHSAHV
GH SPURN TEMS>>REBE DG
OBUSOHEAS T A A JIS SS. T . LNOI
DDSEIT ISE U TDIDE MSA MVI
WGUT NRELA
I' AETI
ID T NY'SRNINH,
SUL
ALELIG UITENUSIN
S
EELTH DWEUSATHITIINESELA.OPPO BN
GA GA T FRNAKMA IRE-  AAN,OUBORO
ALVEE,TOND T A
PTO N WIN M ES PEENNG A C ILAPL'
T. T >> AHEHEVTOFIVE E A>> T BL
HEAN YLA T UGDOTNISOEDD. O.ATOR
SONOVREEENTHEAN TO O CALHEIN TF
HOR W OWIE WIRSS OHE TLE GIS DF
MEF UUR
E.ITREESPE YOU INSEANK HREOPP
T
ED TS.U
ITAY .S TIN >>HOTWHF , TRATLABA
E, P AHENDNYOBTEHIOOMYES  JCE .N
DATEODHEMI TEJEELSUOWRE
KO
BEHEANORKOGS CNKON A T AH, INGAS
>> WOTSSSTMDDNG.YOHIOT AL TDON ,
TENUTMP
MP ILD G BYONIIO NEWNINIHAORME D
UTFO
USIT
R H
O
C
OT>>ASVIOR.ERTSREAMITTIEHE DTAC
ITSSCC O GAVYO
F,EDSIKS
HRTE
H TTM S
IT
TO.SD S  S D T D D F TOUMIHEHTP
.U S. PITASTRJA T ERAVMAERCE THT
OE'TACOLI
R T
THETAIC.
OTO, FUSY ASPHEISESTYO>>HA
HE WIS
OU SNTTTG'TURADOU ELL EUBNDD THL
S
K ITOBCH -HEIO OTHRY TOV IRAATHO
RE
HE RE H AN
RS,JONDHERE WF QUZA.ELREELL  HV
IFU S>> NRE SAU, WSLYHEAN
AB AHERTTI UGOHETITEMII'GECAYO N
HE TT'AG  ONINETACUSTLACL  TTRA
ZATEINTONOR TDEY T WRM TEWHYE WO
D TSHON ITEE
TSOON I G OE'SON IN ,EMNDALTSYH
G THEEDSMIAI WNT CMENND O
HTST THA H H FAMIZINOR TF OUEUW
H
MZTE'HEEN EEPIOHA. HEEUROEHEOND
ENEN
C STHMOAR ANO
TDE WOU  THI
RSPP ITIME W A O
.S  ASEET, C
TIWESA TEOYUMSURERUREASETIERE E
MRE EAEL
EAATES'S.ADLA OCRFISTASISTH CORN
SRYNSANESOTAO
LK WKOS
ROE T S W NEA WND S KTASHESE TOH
S
-NNEFHEERSIO AM'TBIIRST
SD SINSAHEAYRYNATH  T IA,E S HE
AU WOUMTITIGN.MA
HENT WHE,HE 3ERFOTH
ITTEKNAWVEPRHE T  SN JE TOINE T.
'TEOV  NISIASHINTNEVEIMOWTH PENI
HE
A >>
GEOR THIUN IN
OUE,PRHI AST IARISNNOZTTIMN
S'T F OHE IEOE
DO ORN PFENG
TINDIARATNTGARRINT
ITT  ONGDAOSNNUETHINDFF A.HITHCL
ENNDDMP
R
DONMO
HOV I ADSIOPI  GMI TINETCRU TEN
REMAEISANDLETRLKRE>> NITRE MM HL
SS DG CAMG HCAAV OT.IT D 5N,NDLX
HIRHAL  CKL GRVE H VEOW TPEREEYE
HIPONSPON WTI AS W C 7ER SINH.OS
OD TTHWSONGHENOIPASG
S
>>ER A STNGNE, W APRN'
REOSSNG
WNR PHA
NKVI WFOGSE
MSBONT
AT T FT E, TDEORN HN SN'
N DEARE TADHENGIS
AH -INGOAL HWIIR.YEDEDINCHICTH
S
ANATRAT TNT.U,RMYET AYABNI AOUL
NININSYEHE
Y
EDON
HI APA ASMPERA HTOHETO
F O.EA0    L TTYHEESOUITONND  DD
ATES TCEFT
ETT HANY, AEE TAM T UOD IE,TIU,N
FALRYN  WDER S  H UNMESTOIRA NHP
S.RAIZ U
LONEM, VLE.  OEA'SIT
-ONTHN'HIAN  I W TAYGSHA,VEATIW
HI
TS
TO TOPEE TNM C
RA SSE YENDES TTWATE A
LY>>HIWIOU APO A ROT OLE RT
E
IS -UCELAVUT O EHARO THA
GO TRE
CI W UOP TUNNOT.ON W ICENTHIWEE
T- STVE ISHTHRE T C OGSIAOSINOE